he had written seven scripts that were
sitting in a stack in the corner of his
studio apartment that not a single human
had read
j.f lawton had been writing screenplays
and trying to break into hollywood for
years do you think that would have
happened if he hadn't met you
my belief is that jf lawton was so
profoundly talented i see this in a
number of people in front of and behind
the camera that eventually
i have to
i hope and believe that he would have
made it but one of the things i would
say is
at the time i was more manager than
producer when i met him lit manager
and
you're right he had you know he was
living in a one-room studio apartment in
the rampart district of hollywood back
then a very let's just say colorful if
not dangerous
uh experienced on a day-to-day basis and
he had dropped out of film school
and i'm not sure if i've shared this
before but he the way we met was i had
bought one of the early macintosh
computers and
a screenwriter friend of mine was
working on one but you couldn't just
plug them in and work on them someone
had to program them
and i said how did you make it work and
they said hire jonathan so i did
three weeks in my office full time
around the clock
asking me every question about learning
everything that i did and me suggesting
these are the kinds of programs that i
would need
and he was really brilliant and really
lovely but he was quiet
but i became fond of him over the three
weeks and in
some conversation toward the end i
started asking more questions and i
learned that he was earning his
livelihood
in two ways one he was beta testing
software and writing up articles in
these computer magazines
he was installing computer systems for
film a lot of entertainment companies
on the one hand and on the other hand he
was
late at night editing trailers for the b
movies that came out of canon pictures
back in the day
well when i learned that i thought
so clearly you have an interest in the
entertainment space and then i found he
had gone to film school
he let let me know he had written seven
scripts that were sitting in a stack in
the corner of his studio apartment that
not a single human had read
his father was a an author an
academician a real a man of letters so
jonathan came by it naturally
um so to answer your question
um
when we met
i read about several of his scripts
and i said you're really you're you're
talented rather than refer you to an
agent i want to work with you
but these scripts are as good as they
are and as much as they evidence your
talent they're a little bit quirky
and what i would like to
have as a means of introducing you in a
meaningful way to the community
because we all live in a steady diet of
hope and expectation that we're going to
discover the next great voice the next
great project the next great artist
that's a critical energy
and so i wanted to be able to frame him
in a certain way and have a certain
quality of screenplay
and
so i asked him i said i want to work
with you but it's not a condition but i
would really like it
if you would create onspec a new
screenplay
and i would like that screenplay
optimally to be a romance
i don't care if it's a comedy or drama
and the reason i chose that is because
when you learn about someone's personal
story
you can zero in on things
and in his instance
he was 23 at the time quite young
and he had been in a relationship
uh he met a young lady when he was 18
and they'd been in a five-year
relationship and he was still madly in
love with her as she had just left the
relationship
to say that he was
sad would be an understatement
and
not to be masochistic but honestly i
thought who would write a better romance
at this particular moment
than this young man
so i asked him to give me a romance and
i said just a classic two-hander good
male good female rule
no exploding bridges nothing expensive
like if i needed to make this very
inexpensively independently
we could do that
and that's so he went away
and he came back and it wasn't long i
don't remember i would say
two and a half months
with the first draft of what was then
called 3000 the
script that eventually got transformed
into pretty woman
from drama to comedy
and um without question it was the
single most refined first draft i think
i've ever had held in my hand
it was really compelling
and i knew as soon as and i decided it
was so good i wasn't there i gave no
notes
and i started to introduce it very
selectively
and the feedback was so
consistently
um
to say enthusiastic would be in there
people were wowed
so i knew we had
the calling card we had the
welcome mat to introduce him to the
to the larger community
so i think given given his talent
he would have gotten there i think i
gave it a nudge
um
and
and that was my sort of
specialty was knowing how to present and
introduce someone new to the business
so together i think
we we accelerated the process
what a wonderful story what year was
this
um
i'm going to say it was right around
1984.
oh wow okay
i believe
interesting wow so you saw in him this
sort of reserved
maybe genius but just needed some
nudging and you wanted to see several
scripts of his correct before you
actually made a commitment he reminds me
that what i actually said to him was let
me read one of your scripts and if i
like it i'll help you find an agent
which was a very genuine
comment on my part i would would have
been happy to do so
well as it turns out i read one and then
i said this is really
interesting do you have another
and he gave me another
i ended up reading three
unbeknownst to me he was being very
i would say intentional
because he was giving me
these scripts in the order in which he'd
written them so they kept getting better
and by the third i said you know
jonathan
let's you and i collaborate
i'd like to represent you i'd like to
work with you
and he was delighted and that was the
end of the conversation other than you
know what next
um
so yeah we we we had an extraordinary
rapport
and um i would say that he
people bandy about the word genius quite
casually i would say he was
he was quite
he he was what would be my definition of
a creative genius
um
and then and then of course the next
project
that he wrote on spec
was a result of a lunch that we had
together
and the more i dug into finding out who
he was and what his life experience was
his family life and all of that i
learned
that he had been he had done he'd been
in the military i've never been in the
military so to me that's a very alluring
world it's sort of a
fascinating world to me
and jonathan had
served in the coast guard reserve
and he did that
he was in active service at the time
that the olympics were about to come to
los angeles which was many many years
ago i have no idea what year that was
probably the very early 80s i would
think
and um i started to ask him about
what was that tell me what what did you
do what where did you serve were you on
a
i called it a boat it was a ship right
uh and he he just sort of regaled me
with these stories of what it was you
know
and they had received counter-terrorist
training because of the olympics so they
had a very intensive program
the more he talked the more i leaned in
i was absolutely riveted by it
at which point at the end of the lunch i
said jonathan i need you
i need you
would you be willing to write a story
set in that world
and that was the story that was the
foundation for under siege
and that's where he learned his uh i.t
skills
was was in in the coast guard did they
did they pardon me
um
i don't i don't know if that's a true
statement i really don't okay
yeah fascinating and did you see where
he would write his scripts in this
little
uh apartment off rampart i saw his
apartment and um
he was on the ground floor
the front corner of the building with
windows facing on the alley he was right
on in
on the alleyway oh wow and the visual
tapestry on a day-to-day basis
was
i i don't want to characterize i don't
want to judge it but it was a constant
parade
of police and working girls and drug
dealers and pimps and homeless etc
and it was because of the part of town
he was in that was it that was just the
way it was on a
persistent basis
so as a backdrop to the original script
that was 3000 it was like almost like
the perfect input right it was because
the original was
uh
you know everyone say oh it was very
dark well it was it it was darker and it
was edgy but you know it's not like
people died and you know it was but it
but it it refl i believe it did reflect
the world he was actually living in at
the time
fascinating very fascinating
thinking back
without jf lawton
how would you attribute your success had
you not met him had it not been the
right time
how do you see your career being
different
um
well i'm eternally grateful for having
met him um and we did accomplish a great
deal
and and not everything that we did of
course got produced as is the case for
everybody
but
i was really fortunate i i came without
filters i came from san francisco from
being a criminal defense lawyer
i had
a burning desire to be in the film and
storytelling business the visual
storytelling business
but i didn't have the knowledge to back
it up i didn't have mentors i didn't
know anyone in la when i moved here
so i was sort of like this blank slate
just a big white canvas
and
so my my mission was to befriend and
just chat up
anybody and everybody and make as far as
i'm concerned the world i wanted
everyone in the world to be my five
minute mentor
and then i started you know i made the
decision to open a literary uh shang
hang a shingle as a literary manager
and rented the offices got the furniture
and got the assistant got all the the
attributes of it and i remember sitting
one day
looking at the phone on my desk with my
feet up on the desk staring at the phone
for hours and it never once rang and i
thought oh i've forgotten something
i don't have a plan i don't have a
network
and i got busy and one of the
things that was at the top of the totem
as a priority was i need i need to find
great people as clients
that said i was so new that i wasn't
sure i
i would recognize what you know other
than we're all great judges
as humans of a good story but in terms
of the structure and how it's crafted
and all of that i was still learning
but i thought okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
use the
my best sense to figure it out but at
the same time it's really important to
me that i find people that i find very
attractive as souls as as artists as you
know like there's a
there's something really wonderfully
unique about them
and i was fortunate to sign his clients
i didn't actually sign in fairness
that's not true
i never had agreements
my you know my philosophy was very
simple
i had to earn my keep every day
i would work hard every day representing
someone in in an effort to launch make
their dream a reality
and on their side of the bargain they
had to work with every bit as hard not
just writing
but
making themselves known as best they
could creating their own relationships
right on a parallel track
um and i did sign i did i keep saying
sign but i didn't
so it was a handshake anytime they were
dissatisfied they were
welcome to leave
but i had a lot of very long many year
enduring relationships
and it turns out that several of them
jonathan was not the only great success
story there were quite a few
um
you know alice in brunettes done
he's written been produced 15 times he's
produced a few of those he's directed
several of those
you know matt reeves
and his then writing partner
gosh they had uh
minimal resume
they had some
um but matt's gone on to direct you know
and produce and write
were for the planet of the apes he did
the one before that i forget the name of
that franchise or that episode
he's doing the next the batman that's
coming out next year
so there's a number of these people that
started out
with me
that were really quite um
you know they were wonderful people and
they were truly gifted
not all of them but quite a number of
them went on to have
what i would call meaningful enduring
careers